la ceremonia de apertura es la
marcador principal hace mil millones y
media gente que va a ver el
ceremonia de apertura de los juegos
Juegos Olímpicos
necesariamente queremos que
entender todo lo que francia
hoy representa todo lo que tiene
traído a la historia de los juegos que queremos
no solo será la 33ª edición de
juegos en algún lugar queremos ser uno
nuevo modelo para la organización de juegos
el deporte en la ciudad capitaliza
los valores del deporte capitalizan los
valores de Francia para ofrecer un
plantilla de celebración de juegos
absolutamente único
[Música]
Bien
por primera vez en la historia de
juegos vamos a organizar un desfile de
atletas en el centro de la ciudad en el
escenificar la llegada de los 10.500 atletas que
vendrán de 206 países que entrarán
en paris quien cruzara paris
de este a oeste para encontrarse
descubre los paisajes más bellos de
nuestro país con esta ciudad con
museos estoy pensando en el musée d'orsay en
louvre en el gran palacio el más hermoso
puente también este nuevo puente que es el puente
el mas historico de paris
[Aplausos]
[Música]
En
menos seiscientas mil personas está en
Di diez veces más
dos personas que en un estadio
Stade de France, por ejemplo, así que es
realmente una primera vez sin precedentes
guardia donde logramos casarnos más
hermosa de nuestra historia de nuestra cultura
del patrimonio una ceremonia sumamente
espectacular
[Música]
una ciudad como paris no puede hacer
juegos solo por lo que podría
verlos donde participa y no un
ciudad como paris que tambien es la ciudad
en el que todos los
declaraciones de derechos universales
humanos y bueno esta ciudad tenia que
también llevan otro mensaje de los juegos
popular entre una audiencia que accede
y para gran parte de este público
gratis en este extraordinario espacio
y a este evento planetario
[Música]
[Aplausos]
así que realmente estamos trabajando en un
distribución hay un memorando de entendimiento
que se ha comprometido con la ciudad de París
el estado y parís 2024 para distribuir todo
los recursos disponibles para
seguridad para garantizar que el evento
estar en completa confianza y dejar que sea
en las plataformas bajas en las plataformas altas
en el espacio aéreo hay un verdadero
un reparto real de las responsabilidades de
habilidades por lo que no tenemos un número de
personas para contactarlo hoy
pero la buena noticia es que todos y
todas estas autoridades competentes han
declaró la viabilidad de una ceremonia
en el escenario
[Aplausos]
[Música]
también
[Aplausos]
allá
[Música]